newly-released radio calls show the
first effort to warn police about the
gunman in las the Las Vegas Massacre a
hotel maintenance worker called down
from the 32nd floor of Mandalay Bay
after a security guard was shot the
recording raises more questions about
the police response Jamie yuccas is
outside the Mandalay Bay Resort and
Casino Jamie good morning good morning
this has many people wondering why the
shooter stopped his gunfire after a
hailstorm of bullets first into the
hotel hallway and then onto hundreds at
a country concert below these are some
of the first gun shots fired by Steven
paddock from inside his suite at
Mandalay Bay Steven Jacque used his
radio to let hotel staff know about the
terror unfolding on the 32nd floor
security guard hey-zeus Campos was
already shot I can't tell you what room
he looked like he played on the hallway
after Chuck's call it's still unclear
when exactly the Mandalay Bay staff
called the police
nobody's trying to hide anything
originally Clark County Sheriff Joseph
Lombardo had said Campos interrupted the
shooter but now Lombardo says those
first shots were fired six minutes
before Patek started his rampage what we
want to do is draw the most accurate
picture we can and I'm telling you right
now today that that timeline might
change again
investigators say Patek did not have any
gambling debts and his girlfriend did
not worry about his mental health but
his motive is still unclear the first
lawsuit by a victim has been filed page
gaspers family is suing a number of
parties they believe were negligent in
this shooting including MGM which owns
Mandalay Bay in an interview with the
Las Vegas review-journal sheriff
Lombardo says an autopsy has been
performed on paddock and no brain
abnormalities have been found all right
thank you very much Jamie